Cerdic Akhmim has gotten used to the
explosions but the jeweler still does
not feel safe enough to travel to his
shop in downtown diab occur very often
he hasn't opened his business in more
than a month the street behind his shop
has been the scene of bitter street
fighting between the PKK and Turkish
security forces our electricity and
water must cut off 40 days ago but but
it's even worse for the people who live
over there in the sewer district there
are 100,000 residents there and most of
them had to flee from the fighting the
Kurdish city in southeast Turkey has
seen the worst fighting in decades in
the last few weeks alone more than 170
civilians are reported to have been
killed here and elsewhere in the region
in violence between the Turkish army and
irregular Kurdish forces Turkish
security forces have so far failed to
drive the PKK fighters out of central dr
bakr but the Turkish government has
rejected called for a ceasefire saying
it will fight the terrorists until they
are defeated in a local human right
center relatives of victims of the
fighting have started a hunger strike
because they have been prevented from
recovering the corpses of their sons
brothers and daughters to bury them my
brother joined the guerrillas five month
ago he experienced so much injustice
from the state he was put in prison for
three month although he was innocent
tetanus which isn'ta call the kitchen
utensil DOJ's I'm descrition the Turkish
flag as provocation hate and mistrust
between ethnic Kurds and Turks has
increased again it is the civilian
population that bears the brunt and more
and more people are fleeing the areas
where the fighting is going on behind
these barriers a civil war is taking
place while the world looks the other
way just a year ago there was hope for a
lasting peace settlement now the Turkish
government seems to want to solve the
Kurdish conflict militarily rather than
political
a strategy that has shown little signs
of success for the past 35 years as the
civilian population grows more desperate
ethnic Kurdish politicians are trying to
broker a compromise so far without
success the government has arrested a
number of local mayor's from a Kurdish
party on alleged terrorism charges yeah
ik baby i am to get me back around the
table even if it's with the Akbar T
government young only on this dialogue
we have not given up hope she could've
silicic man and his fellow shop owners
have also not given up hope they plan to
reopen their business in downtown dr
bakr but for now they will continue to
do business in the shadow of Turkish
army tanks